[Music]
in civilian bodycam news bowl on big
Johnson what's up it's a big dick is
that Dwayne Johnson the big one maybe I
need was a fan mmm [ __ ] fanboy I love
you Bart a new shortcut for iPhones can
automatically record your interactions
with the police huh good cuz they be
harassing me for my Dimebag 24/7 I think
that's what ghetto people do I was like
a really bad caricature all right cool
no no I'm saying just that like t-rex
arms for no reason
I have bought a diamond ages man how do
you do small now no get them in stores
now just go to a [ __ ] dispensary yeah
so there's this new feature
yeah it's called there's an app called
shortcuts where it you can create these
shortcuts in combination of all your
favorite apps so for example you can say
like hey you know when I arrive home
open my garage through that one app
right and then once you walk in and open
the light through this other app that I
have on my phone but it's like all
through this one app so it just op
programs it and does it like that
yeah if you have like a smart home where
you have like all the lights in your
room oh that's or it could be other
things too
like you go to your coffee spot and
that's once you get there you want this
particular song to play or whatever it's
like all these other things that you can
do or you can have it take a photo or
record from your camera whenever you
that's not so dope but I'm so lazy to
even set it up that's the hard part the
setting up yeah yeah it's kind of like
um the IFFT
I forgot what this one app it's called
if this and that then you can do all
that stuff like for example if you post
on Instagram this photo then immediately
the post it to Twitter gonna move my
cars for me that's what that's what
really like troubles your life moving
your cars so everything yes
every morning that I train right I do
the same routine so which is why I have
to wake up 15 minutes earlier that's
right move the cars out of the driveway
oh not to make coffee right what I have
to go on Pandora Pandora that I have to
click new jack swing you click it yeah
but imagine minute my alarm wakes up and
the cars go loose coffee makes it sorry
we gotta start this music movie how did
the Tom move driving apart
yeah can we start to go find help all
the self-driving cars are gay though
that's the problem
Tesla's not gay this self-driving yeah
you know got a big mouth part yeah right
you know they actually have a upgrade
for it right now it's not legal in
California but I think they're getting
illegal in other states where the car
actually drives surface streets and a
freeway by itself with you not doing it
mythical did you know that your car
dances oh I heard about I know how to do
it though yeah you have to find out but
I don't need the car to dance into my
driveway I need the park itself there's
an easter egg that they program in a
little bit making the car right now
where you just put an address in and
it'll take you to your destination I got
my report is happening I got this email
that uh Apple and this year is gonna
test eighty self-driving cars on the
streets you know what that means
they might even come out the car the
iCard Apple to make a car talked about
that she came out of just never lose
yeah we did we weren't a long time ago
I'd be surprised if if they came out
with a chip it's like a potato chip a
potato chip Apple potato chips how
confusing an apple potato chip when you
think it's an apple no but it's a potato
chip
potato chips so an AI potato pie
potatoes III chips
potatoes so this app here it's called
police and it works with that shortcuts
at all this yeah and so that app what it
does is you could say hey Siri I'm
getting pulled over immediately the
program pauses the music you could be
playing turns down the brightness on
your iPhone and then turns on do not
talk it goes on secret mode yeah it
immediately starts recording from your
front facing camera and then it also
immediately notifies a predetermined got
contact that you have been pulled over
and then it sends your location to that
contact so they that's amazing yeah it's
like all these things kind of sad but
it's amazing yeah so you you set it up
yourself since I send a message it's
like to who and then say I'm getting
pulled over my current location is this
at the latitude and longitude and then
take video with the camera the front
save it to your camera rule or like you
could upload it to the cloud man when I
was drugged ill and that would have been
perfect so you could eliminate yourself
you're actually doing the wrong thing
dude no I mean like you want to get out
of trouble so you want to when the cops
come you can use it against them or
whatever you could try to get them to
slip up I don't know yeah so the Creator
this ever saying the same like you know
cops have body cams this could be like
the civilian version of that where like
both sides have evidence shouldn't be
like that though I know right that's
what I'm saying it's also like a lot of
just normal decent ass people that get
[ __ ] over by the yeah that's sad dude
there's normal decent police I get
[ __ ] over I don't understand that's
why you need both yeah you know you
could tell how you grew up by the way
you produce a police yeah police yeah I
used to say I didn't realize this until
somebody mentioned it to me
they said you say police really funny
yeah I say police yeah Poli I said
paulista yeah I didn't [ __ ] realize
that [ __ ] was like a ghetto thing oh is
it
yeah cuz they're like oh the police you
mean police yeah they're like no police
please no you try to say please right
now it's police I'm trying to correct
them I think they're right though it's
police yeah yep police I just said cops
I think when you hang on the Oh too long
that's a little bit
Oh Lisa's gonna I've changed it now it's
police cuz I don't want to believe yeah
like it sounds out like please please
what about police say police lethea
that's next level yeah so what the [ __ ]
or leap three what the [ __ ] is the
police doing over there you know police
or you can get out of all that and just
call them the popos oh yeah just kind of
just put it right in there what's the
[ __ ] pigs do it open there you go
yeah police it's not my bacon
what else is another word for cops just
pigs 5:05 yeah really yeah cool though
some people are so cool little bird
called to cuss still make you nervous
till this date yeah dude
even back then I really didn't do much
either but they still made me hella
nervous I don't know why I never done
anything bad and I get nervous I can't I
can't get over that feeling of them
making me feel weird even after when I
joined the Marine Corps what I'm like
okay I'm on your side now there's so
many [ __ ] bets down in the police
department yeah I get pulled over I have
a [ __ ] Marine Corps sticker on the
back of my truck I'm wearing a [ __ ]
Marine Corps t-shirt I'm sitting there
and they pull over but they see like the
tattoo and you know you're working for
the Triads aren't you
he told you that yeah there's a asian
cop that pulled me over at Monterey Park
and he goes what do you know about Asian
gangs I might use square ass
[ __ ] like if you actually knew
and you grew up in the hood one look at
me and you would know that I have
nothing to do with it but I think he was
one of those super whitewashed asian
guys that he just didn't even know so he
just saw a tattoo and he was like uh
this guy must be when it is agent gaynes
I learned about in-depth atomy it sounds
like a cool surfer yeah probably oh wait
what what would give it away like how
what would be the thing that would be
wearing a military t-shirt
oh I don't have this bottom half yeah
but like this is not a gang Asian style
tattoo me this kind of is everyone every
one of the sgv got their tattoo from one
person pretty much at that time and you
do have the dragon but it's not even the
same it's not that kind of drag came
from what this one place is stuff like
that everyone all went to so you would
know and then also like I wouldn't have
a Marine Corps sticker on the back I
would do wearing a t-shirt that's the
way I dress the way I drove I was
[ __ ] driving like this yeah you were
just so it weren't you driving like a
lifted truck yeah I was driving a Tahoe
like there was just BR uh the Tacoma
like it was just there's so many signs
you know I did what they would know that
I'm on he wouldn't make good cops during
that area like we could sniff it out so
easy that's why there was a Asian gang
task force yeah back in those times
because they didn't even know that you
know they existed so they had to have
like a special like unit that was like
oh [ __ ] now we don't know the difference
so they did a lot of like recon and and
and they just pulled everybody over
because at that time they didn't know
who was what everybody looked the same
to them and then they started figuring
out like what the difference were and
the styles the fashion I want to I want
it to be more up though okay yeah and
then you could tell too cuz back then it
was clear like you could tell by the way
they dressed what they got on how many
times they spit on the floor for no
reason the type of cars they chose like
everything had there's just so many
signs so many signs
I've never back in the day everything
was gay I didn't even know you guys
existed Asian Games yeah I just thought
you guys were copying like chillest and
I'm like look at these [ __ ] like
[ __ ] posers I like Asian drivers
though they [ __ ] leave their car seat
all the way back like this and they
[ __ ] drive on that bottom wheel like
this is [ __ ] but those are from the
cholo time so I always not I always
thought the Asian people were
such fighters I'm like yo like why don't
you get your own stuff so good I thought
they was gonna go to sleep or something
said boo wake up there was Asian style
but then in our generation the guy
started copying like a lot of the Mex
King looks in the sgv let's see you guys
got those hanging like the bell and
shinny Ortez is I'm like what guys are
trendsetters dude what can you say I
think we won't make copying on purpose
we just started shopping that meets
these Chuck's cortezes that's true cuz
all the swap meet drink to the atoll oh
yeah that's all the market I didn't know
that there's the swap meet at flea
markets would have nothing but Asian and
Mexican vendors are like you want to
have the first the funniest thing the
[ __ ] RMB Hawaiian singers they
[ __ ] dress like East LA gangbangers
dude if you notice that yeah yeah it was
like [ __ ] locusts but they're all
armed be [ __ ] like quartets and [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] hilarious if you know it is
still like go ghetto style all over the
world it hasn't changed much and then
they all like the same [ __ ] because even
like white people do the same [ __ ]
[Music]